Walmart in Georgia now has a police
station one of their stores inside the
store if you think crime is you know a
concern for people when they're putting
a police station inside of a Walmart and
we looked into this and you know police
they have those you know 187 means a
murder I think and and 5150 is a you
know mental patient they have all these
2 213 is a robbery I think they have all
these so we looked at some of the ones
that they have for the police station in
the
Walmart would you like to he some of the
ones that I thought you
would of course um they have the uh oh a
1074 that's item in store being used by
a customer as Kleenex
that's is the the 4120 Rascal scooter
jack knife blocking self
checkout
um oh a 10-11 that's Kid Rock shooting
beer
uh 1089 that's racist Karen in
altercation with anti-mass
Karen yeah
uh uh 1470 shoplifter needs
assistance um in 1871 is congresswoman
giving hand job to Store
Club
uh 1067 is an illegally parked
[Applause]
home and uh a 1531 is man in candy Isle
insisting Skittles is a pride
display